cette matinale par cette déclaration
plutôt alarmistes des états unis hier
soir le département d'état américain a
envoyé un communiqué à ses diplomates en
ukraine pour leur demander de partir il
invoque une possible opération militaire
russe sans donner plus de précisions un
ordre qui intervient alors que la russie
et les etats unis continuent de discuter
de la crise en ukraine ce week end
londres a accusé le kremlin de chercher
à installer un dirigeant pro russe à
kiev on va voir cela tout de suite avec
notre correspondant à moscou antoine
claireaux
[Musique]
bonjour antoine où vous êtes à moscou
qu'en est il exactement on va peut-être
entendre avant votre intervention est la
déclaration du département américain et
on en parle juste après
le ministère conseille aux citoyens
américains de ne pas se rendre en
ukraine le 23 janvier il a autorisé le
départ volontaire d'employés et ordonné
le départ de membres de leurs familles
de l'ambassade de kiev en raison de la
menace continue d'une action militaire
russe voilà pour cette déclaration
antoine quelle réaction à moscou
mais bien tout d'abord c'est un
communiqué ce week-end un communiqué de
la part de la diplomatie britannique qui
a fait réagir moscou la diplomatie russe
a publié un communiqué en retour dans
lequel elle demande aux britanniques de
mettre fin à leurs activités
provocatrices et d'arrêter de diffuser
des absurdités dans la journée de
dimanche la porte-parole du ministère
russe des affaires étrangères est
intervenu lors d'une émission politique
à la télévision l'a fait savoir que
l'occident préparer le chan
informationnel à une série de
provocations majeur écoutez
on prépare la conscience publique
l'opinion publique à cela pour
l'occident collectif pour l'otan pour
les anglo saxons il est extrêmement
important de créer un champ
informationnel sans lequel ils ne
peuvent pas agir pourquoi font-ils cela
dans quel but nous n'excluons pas de
futur manipulation majeur de
l'information et des provocations et
nous n'excluons pas non plus des
provocations militaires notamment et
qu'en est-il de l'union européenne
présente tel un front uni dans cette
crise ukrainienne on a vu berlin refusé
par exemple 2 livré des armes à kiev
oui tout à fait kiev également réagi à
ce que la diplomatie russe qualifie d'
intox de la part des britanniques ainsi
la présidence ukrainienne a réaffirmé sa
volonté de continuer à diallo de
continuer à dialoguer la bourrine la
présidence ukrainienne qui a au
contraire réaffirmé sa volonté de
continuer à démanteler tous groupe je
cite tout groupe pro russe du pays pour
rappel kiev a fait fermer trois chaînes
de télévision d'opposition la dernière
accusé de répandre des de la
désinformation rice
merci beaucoup antoine pour toutes ces
précisions antoine claireaux en direct
de moscou ce matin